Speaker 1: There is a new report from Axios
reporter Jonathan Swan, which tells the story
of a Donald Trump temper tantrum in which,
after losing the twenty twenty election, Trump
tried to just pull troops from around the
world.
Now, you might think, that's great, I want
to bring our troops home.
We shouldn't have troops all over the world
the way that we do.
And I would agree with you, but this was not
a foreign policy calculation by Donald Trump.
This was not a well crafted decision to reduce
the military presence around the world.
This was not a calculated and much discussed
strategy for reducing the spread of the American
military throughout the globe.
This was a temper tantrum over losing the
election on November 9th of twenty twenty.
You might remember, that's the day after the
media finally said, OK, Joe Biden won.
John McEntee, one of Donald Trump's favorite
aides, gave a note to Army Colonel Colonel
Douglas MacGregor.
And on that note, it said, this is what the
president wants you to do, get us out of Afghanistan,
get us out of Iraq and Syria, withdraw completely
from Germany and get us completely out of
Africa.
And McGregor explained, you know, we can't
really just do this by January 20th.
And I certainly just can't do it by myself.
And McKenty said to MacGregor, well, do what
you can.
And McGregor said, I really can't do anything
I need, like a real order from the president.
I can't just go and pull all of our troops
from around the world two days later.
And this is all based on Jonathan Swan's Axios
reporting.
Such a letter was delivered to the acting
secretary of defense, Christopher Miller.
All U.S. military forces are to be withdrawn
from Somalia by December 31st.
All U.S. forces are to be withdrawn from Afghanistan
by January 15th with similar unrealistic dates.
And Miller wondered, what the hell is going
on here?
The Department of Defense called the White
House a lawyer, Patrick Maloney, and asked
what is going on here?
They called Trump's national security adviser,
Robert O'Brien.
No one had any idea what was going on.
This wasn't a plan.
This wasn't policy.
This was just a very strange temper tantrum.
And as Jonathan Swan writes for Axios, the
US government's top national security leaders
soon realized they were dealing with an off
the books operation by Trump himself.
Ultimately, it didn't happen.
But as you can see, this is not the action
of a president who wanted to do these things
because they were the right things to do.
If they were, he wouldn't have waited until
November 9th of the last year of his first
term to do it.
It was a triggered, tilted man, furious that
he lost, seemingly wanting to create as much
chaos as possible for Joe Biden, who would
be replacing him just two months later.
And as Jonathan Swan writes, quote, Christopher
Miller told Associates he had three goals
for the final final weeks of the Trump administration.
No one, no major war, No.
Two, no military coup.
And No.
Three, no troops fighting citizens on the
streets of the United States.
Think about the insanity of the situation
when the acting national security adviser,
acting secretary of defense, says my goals
for the lame duck period are preventing Trump
from starting a war, preventing Trump from
using the military for a coup and preventing
Trump from deploying troops to fight citizens
on the streets of the United States.
The more we read stories like this one, the
more we realize just how insanely close we
came to an even greater level of chaos.
The stuff that was apparently narrowly avoided
almost makes the January 6th insurrection
look relatively mild in comparison.
And between the riots and Trump trying to
overturn the election results and stay in
power and on a whim saying pull all troops
from everywhere and having lawyers in and
talking about martial law or seizing voting
machines or whatever else, the stuff that
happened is bad enough.
But look at all of the things we're learning
about that almost happened.
And as I've said, when Donald Trump left,
it was way worse than we knew over time.
Where?
Going to learn more, but I don't know that
will ever really learn the full scope of exactly
how bad it was.
And this is just yet another thing.
And I know that, you know, there are probably
going to be people in my audience.
I've already seen it in other enclaves.
There's probably some people in my audience
who maybe identify with what is sometimes
called the revolutionary left, who will say
this was Trump outflanking the left on the
spread of the American military.
Trump was trying to pull troops from all these
places that troops arguably shouldn't even
be in.
And now leftists like David Pakman are saying
that it was a bad idea.
I'm not saying it was a bad idea.
And I've been arguing for drawing down troops
in Germany and in many other places for a
decade on this program.
The point is, this wasn't policy.
This was the day after the election was called
for.
Biden, Trump, without consulting with anyone
and for no strategic reason, for no well thought
out foreign policy reason just says I'm going
to create an S storm for lack of a better
term for Joe Biden and just start pulling
troops haphazardly.
It is not policy.
And this is not how anybody who is a thinking
individual would say it should be done.
We should be drawing down troops.
We should be reducing our military footprint.
There's no question about it.
But if you do it as policy, you don't do it
once.
You're already a lame duck.
That doesn't make any sense.
And that's pathetic